Hello.
Welcome to part two
of the DPR lecture,
history and
physical exam for
pediatrics, six to
10 years of age. This
is Dr. Patel again.
If you watched my
first video, thank
you for watching.
This one won't be
as long, I promise.
And hopefully you
can learn something
fun about six-year
-olds and 10-year-olds.
OK, so these are some
of the things we're
going to talk about.
we're going to talk
about basic well child
visit, interviewing,
history taking, like
we did similarly.
So toddler group, we're
also going to talk
about growth, the
AAP recommendations,
site screenings, vaccine
schedule, likely
pathologies that
you'll see in
this age range,
scoliosis testing,
Tanner staging,
and then just end
with resources.
Okay, so in well
child visits for these
patients, we want to
focus on school, grades.
This is the time
where they start
getting harder
classes, more material.
So things like
learning disabilities,
ADHD really come about
during this time.
You always want to
ask about screen time
because that could be
interfering with their
studying, with their
sleep, with their diet,
everything, exercise.
These days, it's
very common to find a
person with screen time
that is way too long
for them. We try
to say to limit the
screen time to two
hours, but I know that's
very hard because a
lot of their homeworks
and assignments will
be online. So you
have to take that
with a grain of salt.
I also want to always
ask them about their
diet and exercise, making
sure they're getting
good calcium. They
need about two to three
servings of calcium a
day. So whether they
get that in drinking
milk or yogurt or cheese
ingestion and then
exercise, like are
they involved in activities
any sports um they
there's a lot of
research that says sports
participation is really
good for team building
skills um and
preventing children from
making bad decisions in
the future um they're
all it's also important
to establish good
sleeping habits so
sleeping at least nine
hours a night is crucial
to their to their
development and learning
um dentist visits making
sure they're brushing
twice a day they're
seeing the dentist
once every six months.
Definitely visual
screening. So a
lot of times
they'll be like, oh,
the board is
blurry. I have to
sit closer to the
board to see it.
So need for glasses.
I remember the first
time I got glasses,
it was like I was
seeing everything new
for the first time,
like all the lines
and the leaves. It
was really remarkable
because it's progressive.
You don't realize
how bad your vision
is until you have
you're forced to see
something and read
something that you
can't actually read.
And then when you get
glasses, it changes
your life. So definitely
for these kids,
it's something that
we want to ask about.
And then our
clinic would do the
visual screening,
so that also helps.
If they have some
sort of abnormality, I
usually refer them to
the optometrist or the
ophthalmologist who can
help them get the glasses
that they need. um
the aap recommends
doing one random lipid
screening between the
ages of 9 and 11 years
of age it doesn't have
to be fasting um it's
just like a random test
uh just to make sure
everything looks okay
and then also cardiac
screening questions
so if there's been any
loss of consciousness
while exercising any chest
pain while exercising
and early cardiac
death in the family.
If there's any
concern for like a
hereditary cholesterol
problem, I definitely
get the lipid
screening earlier,
but this is like if
she's a normal kid.
Also, obesity, which is
defined in pediatrics
as a BMI percentile,
over 95 percentile
for age and *** is a
growing problem. So one
in five U.S. children
and adolescents suffer
from obesity. So it
is a huge problem that
I think requires a lot
of preventative care
and a lot of tender
love and care as well.
So this is what the
BMI percentile looks
like for boys 2 to
20 years of age.
Anything over 95th
percentile is considered
obese, like I said.
Anything from between
85th and 95th is
considered overweight.
And then under
5th percentile is
considered underweight,
things like that.
Um, and we keep checking
those every year
and following up
with them. If there's
something specifically
that we're working
on for the child,
like example, cutting
out all juices and
changing that with
water, um, that's
something we'll follow
them more frequently
for, um, so we
can provide them better
guidance and, and
they can have
accountability for their
hard work, their
hard work, excuse me.
So for blood
pressure, this is for
children's ages one
to 12, and basically
gives you the
normal percentiles.
So for their height,
weight, and ***.
And this is how we
calculate elevated
blood pressure
versus stage
one versus stage
two hypertension.
For children who are
over 13 or about 13,
we use the same
designations as we do for
adults. So we want
normal to be anything
less than 120 over 80
and things like that.
You can usually
MDCalc or Google the
percentiles for their
age and their weight,
which is readily
available online. And then
remember also for heart
rate with children
at rest, between one
and two, they'll have
higher heart rates
like 110, 120s. And
by two to six, that
goes down to 100, 110.
And then by six
years of age to 10
years of age, it
should really be 75
to 90, which is in
the normal range
for a adult as
well. So that helps.
And then we want
to keep an eye on
the length as
well to make sure
they're growing properly.
So short stature
is a very common
complaint you'll
get in the primary
care setting.
And that can be a
number of different
things. It can be
familial, it can be
idiopathic, can be
pathologic, or it could
be just a constitutional
growth delay,
which means that
they will catch up.
It just means that
they're a little bit
younger in terms
of their hormones.
And it'll just take
a little bit of time.
But once they do,
they will catch up
and reach their
optimal height, which
you see in the bottom
kind of blue dotted
line, which is
constitutional delay.
You can see that
they're like low in
their height, but
then they jump up and
catch up at the end
and become their mean.
For familial, so we
calculate a mid-parental
height, which is as
you can see in this
chart right here. So
for girls, it's the
paternal height in
centimeters minus 13 plus the
maternal height divided
by two. Or if you
want to do it inches,
it gives you the
inches. And then for
boys, the same thing, but
if you add the 13
or the 5 instead of
subtracting them.
So that gives you
the mid-parental
height which is
about the estimate of
what the child is
capable of is gonna sit
around um so it's a
combination of both mom
and dad's height um so
oftentimes the parents
are like oh yeah he's
he's so short i don't
know what to do and
then i show them that
they i i graph the mid
-parental height for
them and they realize
that they're actually
also short so that's
why the kid is short.
So some pathological
abnormalities, though,
that can cause short
stature is growth
deficiency. And
then, of course, you
also want to look at
weight because there
could be a malnutrition
component to it.
So usually you'll
see weight go first,
and then the length
will kind of plateau.
So that tells you
that there's some
sort of a malnutrition
or something with
the GI that's
causing the problem.
Celiac is a common
one that causes
growth restriction
or like a failure
for good growth in
weight and height.
I had a patient who they
were actually sisters
and one had really
bad celiac and the
other one did have
celiac but not as bad. So
the one with really
bad celiac was like the
classic. She looked
about the same age even
though she was two
years older than her
sister because she was
just smaller and shorter
um so that's a common
thing that you'll
find and then idiopathic
is we can't find a
reason for it but
they're just short um and
all the tests will be
normal and negative
for that um for the
constitutional delay like
i said um we usually
get a bone age and
the bone age will show
that they're younger.
The bone age will show
that they're actually
younger than what
their chronological age
is, which means that
once they get to what
age you think they
are, that's when the
growth will kind of start
occurring. So they're
just a little bit,
they're late bloomers.
Okay, so this
is the AAP, the
recommendation
for screenings.
And it's separated by
the green is infancy,
the yellow is early
childhood, there's a
middle childhood in the
pink, and then adolescent
is after 11 in the
blue. So at each visit,
you definitely want
to do a history. So
that's what they're
showing you with the dots
that's absolutely
recommended the star is
up to you um so on the
discretionary of the
attending uh you can
see the length height
and weight are also
tested every single year
body mass index and
blood pressure are also
measured every year
after the age of three
vision and hearing
most places will do
every single year as
well developmental
screening and
behavioral social and
emotional screening is
also done every year.
And of course, a
physical exam. For
immunizations, you
also want to assess
every year what they
need. And if they
need something, then
we catch them up.
For anemia, there's not
really any guidelines
in the middle childhood
age, unless they
have some sort of a
history. Remember, that's
usually at one year
of age and then maybe
at two if they have any
other abnormalities.
If they're *********,
then sometimes
we do it at nine
months, but for
the most part, we
do it at one year.
For oral health,
again, we want to, you
know, talk about
fluoride supplementation
if their local
water doesn't not
have fluoride in it
and multivitamin,
and then always
giving anticipatory
guidance to the
family and the parents
about watching things
to watch out for.
okay i quickly want
to talk about aces so
this stands for adverse
childhood experiences
and there are some
screening uh there's
a screening questionnaire
basically and
then you get certain
points for however many
aces you have um and
really it's a lot of
things like um did
you grow up in a
household that had
domestic violence was there
substance ***** was
there a parent that was
incarcerated? Did
you suffer from
homelessness? All those
things give you a point,
an ACE. And what
they found with a lot
of evidence is that
the higher your risk
for ACEs, the higher
your risk for developing
physical and mental
health issues.
Very highly correlative
with obesity,
diabetes,
cardiovascular disease,
******, even
things like, you
know, substance
*****, alcoholism,
things like
that. And I love
Dr. Nadine Burke's book.
And it's called The
Deepest Well, and I put
a picture of it at the
bottom. It's really
good if you're
interested in ACEs or in
pediatrics in general,
about how so much of
the world outside of
our patients affects
our patients' care.
And unless we don't
address those in the
community, we really cannot
give our patients
a wholesome care at
times without thinking
the lens of adverse
childhood experiences
and, and affects everyone,
not just, you know,
poor communities.
Even in affluent
communities, you see
this in all different
types of, of
ethnicities as well.
So this is, this is
definitely a thing
that I've, after
reading the book,
I've clued into more.
And I think it's
really helpful in
caring for my patients
and seeing what
perspective they
have before coming in
or how do I go
about treating them.
And the really, the
idea is that these
stressors and things
can actually change your
epigenetics, which can
then form adaptations,
whether they're poor
or good, and that
can lead to a lot of
high-risk behaviors and
also health conditions.
So it's a really
good book if you guys
get a chance to read
it I really enjoyed
reading it this is the
questionnaire so it's a
10-point questionnaire
that you fill out
and the higher your
ACE the higher chance
of you having you know
the problems that
we talked about okay
depression screening so
we use the PHQ2 which
has basically two
questions do you over the
past two weeks how
often have you been
bothered by any of the
following problems? So
one is little interest
or pleasure in doing
things, so apathy,
or the second one,
feeling down, depressed,
or hopelessness. So
a score of three or
more is considered a
positive result, and
then that should prompt
the PHQ-9, which then
does a deeper depression
screen, which can tell
you whether there's
minor, moderate, or
severe depression.
We start doing these
screenings after
the age of 10,
and it can vary a
little bit based off of
which clinic, but that's
generally where we
start. And then the
grading system is
usually done by points.
So, you know, the
patient will say not at
all or several days or
more than half the
days or nearly every
day, and that's what
gives them the points.
And then the PHQ-9
will go more into, you
know, those two questions
that we asked for
sure. And then also
if they have sleep
trouble, sleep disturbances,
if they're feeling
tired or fatigued,
any appetite changes,
feeling bad about yourself,
trouble concentrating,
basically how it's
affecting their
day-to-day lives. And
then ends with having
any suicidal thoughts
or any thoughts that
you are better off dead
or hurting yourself,
which then clues you
in that there's a lot,
there's severe depression
and this patient
might have some SI
or HI, in which case
you need to get them
help sooner than later.
Okay, let's talk a
little bit about ADHD.
So ADHD stands for
attention deficit
hyperactive disorder,
and it's a common chronic
pervasive
neurodevelopmental disorder.
And it's characterized
by inappropriate
levels of hyperactivity,
impulsivity, and
inattention that
adversely affect their day
-to-day lives. Okay. We
use a objective form,
a questionnaire in
two different settings
to determine whether
this patient may
have ADHD. And that
form is called the
Vanderbilt. So usually
what we do is give one
to the teacher and
one to the parent. And
they have different
ones for each person.
And they'll
individually fill the
questionnaire out, and
then we put it together
and then grade them.
So they have to have
impairments in both
settings in order to
qualify for having
a diagnosis of ADHD.
Some interesting
things are the
inattention part of it is
actually more
common in females.
and in this one
solely the inattention
criteria are
met. It's not the
hyperactivity. In
hyperactivity only ADHD,
those are more
commonly male
and again only
those criteria
are met in the
questionnaire.
Usually most patients
have combined which
means that they
have a little bit of
both inattention and
also hyperactivity,
and that's more common
in males as well.
Usually, those symptoms
always occur before
the age of 12, and
there's a strong
genetic component, but
it is multifactorial.
So usually, we start
seeing symptoms
around four years of
age, and they peak
around seven or eight,
because that's when
the child starts
going to a higher
level of school and
therefore or can have
trouble with the
amount of homework or
the amount of subject
that they're getting
to learn. So sometimes
a lot of those
symptoms can appear
during that time.
They can be motor
restlessness and
disruptive behavior. So
from teachers, they'll
get comments like
they can't sit still
on the chair, and
they're always raising
their hand or
disrupting this time.
And usually the
inattention is usually
a little bit
later, like eight
to nine. years versus
the hyperactivity,
which is a little
bit earlier.
The older kids usually
only have inattention.
Their hyperactivity
is less
pronounced. And again,
there can be mild,
moderate, and severe
degrees of impairment.
What you want to do is
keep your differential
a little bit broad
because it could be
a number of different
things. For example,
you know, a lot of
parents think that
their two-year-old
has ADHD because they
cannot sit still and
they're always moving,
well, that's
normal, appropriate
behavior for their
age. They're not
supposed to be able
to sit there and
read through a whole
book. Some kids
do, but most kids
probably will not.
So determining what's
age-appropriate
behavior, whether they
have anxiety or depression
that could be leading
to some of these
symptoms. If they have
learning disabilities,
again, these all
kind of come out when
the workload gets a
little bit heavier.
If there's any sleep
disturbances, for
example, sleep apnea,
or they're not getting
enough sleep, that can
actually cause irritability
and hyperactivity
in kids, rather than
the common things that
we think about for
sleep apnea or sleep
deprivation. We think
about falling asleep,
which can happen, but
in kids, it can also
lead to hyperactivity.
Chronic illnesses,
substance use, and even
bipolar disease can
also cause some of
these symptoms. So
making sure you're
evaluating for those
and ruling those out.
some symptoms that
can go alongside ADHD
or some diagnoses
are OCD. So you can
have OCD and ADHD
commonly go together.
And then the treatment
for this is really
multimodal. So the most
commonly you'll see
is like stimulants. So
Adderall and Concerta
and Ritalin, those
are all brand name
stimulants that we
normally use. You'll also
see some patients who
don't respond well
to stimulants. They
just, they don't have the
desired effect or
they're too mellow and
they don't retain like
a personality anymore.
And so the parents
choose to change to
sometimes like a non
-stimulant medication.
And then what's also
really important is
doing behavioral therapy
for these patients.
And then making sure
that they have an
IEP, which means they
have an individualized
education program.
So if they do
better in smaller
classes with a para,
which means there's
another person in the
room besides the
teacher to help them.
And so all those
things, longer test
taking time, all
those things kind
of together work to
help the patient.
So really, in your
question stem,
medication plus
behavioral therapy is the
best course of action
for treatment for ADHD.
Okay.
Remember that stimulant
medications also
can suppress a lot
of appetite. So if
they start losing weight
or they're already
low and they're
losing weight, maybe
it's time to change
their medications.
Okay this is what
the Vanderbilt looks
like. So on the one
side you'll see the
parent information and
the other one you'll
see the sorry the
informant and then
other side you'll see
the teacher one. So
as you can see there's
there's different
gradings and such.
So and we can do this
pre and post medication
as well to kind
of assess for how
they're doing on it.
And some parents
will decide to over
the summer not
give their kids the
stimulant medications
because they don't
have to do homework
or they're not forced
to sit in class all
day. So a lot of
them don't need the
stimulant effects
to calm down during
the hyperactivity.
Okay, back to the
vaccine schedule.
So as you can see
in this age range,
and that's the 6
to 10, we're not
doing too much in
terms of vaccines.
The last time they
got vaccines was
usually they'll get
a booster of DTaP.
Again, that's less
than 7, though,
and that'll be
the last dose.
And then also they
get the IPV, the
last dose, the
fourth dose at around
4 to 6. And
then, of course,
they're boosters of
MMR and varicella.
But really, between
7 and 10, they
don't really get
any vaccines.
The next set of
vaccines occur when
they're 11 years old,
when they start getting
Tdap, and then
also meningococcal,
and then HPV as well.
So those are that.
Okay, in this age
range, there are some
likely pathologies
that you will likely
see in your clinical
rotation. So let's
go through them. The
first one is strep
pharyngitis. This is
very common. So the
peak incidence of
this is between ages
five and nine. We
usually use the centaur
criteria, which is
right here in table
one. So that just gives
you a point, every
single one. And the
more points you have,
usually you test
for the rapid strep.
If you have zero
or one point,
that's usually
not required.
So going through
this, the age should
be between the
range that we said.
3 to 14 is the
larger range, but
the peak is usually
between 5 and 9.
What you'll see on
your exam is tonsillar
swelling and exudates.
So you can see a little
bit of that whitish
speck right here, which
is the exudate that
you're seeing on both
sides. You can see
tender, swollen anterior
lymph nodes. So when
you touch them, it's
tender for the patient.
And it's the anterior
cervical chain. Those
are very common to
see in strep. You'll
have absence of a cough,
which usually indicate
a viral process.
A bacterial strep
will just look angry
and red and just
limited to the
throat. And they'll
often have a fever
greater than 38
degrees centigrade.
So that's the
center of criteria.
And what we usually
do is get, this
is just showing
the incidence and
how it's the highest
in ages 5 and 9.
But we usually get
a rapid strep swab.
And then if that's
negative, but our
suspicion is very
high, we go ahead and
send the culture,
which is the gold
standard. If the rapid
is positive, that
means we can just
trust it and we treat
the patient. So the
rapid strep is very
sensitive, but it's
not very specific.
The treatment is beta
-lactam, so penicillin,
amoxicillin, those
are great options
to treat strep
pharyngitis. And then if
it's viral, so say
they have, you know,
runny nose, cough,
they have a little bit
of a fever, but not
so high, and they add
a sore throat,
it's usually viral
pharyngitis, and you
can just do supportive,
especially if their
rapid ****** was
negative and your
suspicion isn't very high.
okay let's talk about
during your oral exam
we want to make sure
we look at dentition
because dental caries
can be very prevalent
at this age and
dental caries can then
progress to gum
disease and and create
abscesses and bad things
so dental caries look
like this at the
bottom here where you
get a little bit of
decaying of the teeth and
then that can actually
go deeper as well
um staining of the
teeth can also be common
especially if they
you know receive
tetracycline is the
classic or they have really
poor oral hygiene um
as well um so this
is staining and then
i just wanted to go
through um the age that
the kiddos will start
developing their
permanent teeth so as
you can see they start
losing their front
teeth first so the
first molars um uh they
start getting in about
six to seven years.
And then slowly
as they're 11, 13,
they'll start
getting more teeth.
And at six to
eight years old,
they'll also
start getting
eruption of the
central incisors.
And so it's important
to know that
they'll be losing
teeth and gaining some
good ones. So as
long as they're doing
good oral health,
that should be very
good for the for
their overall health.
Delayed teeth eruption
can be some sort of
a systemic problem or
genetic disease as well.
So that's something
to also keep in mind.
And of course, the
third molars are the
last to erupt, right?
Like as we're older,
we get like the pain
in the back and then
we have to get our
molars removed. So,
okay.
Constipation, also very,
very common problem
in school-aged children.
so here you have
an x-ray that's full
of stool and the ******
is is dilated with a
stool like heavy stool
burden in there um i
like to give uh kids
this diagram um it's
called the breslow
scale breslow scale
and um even though it's
called breslow school
stool i think it's i
think the L is silent,
I think. But but some
people call it Bristol
score. So it's fine.
So you have different
types of stool
qualities and what
that might mean.
Constipation is
usually type three or
going backwards. So
type two or type one.
Anything anything four
and down is considered
fine. And then seven
is too it's it's too
watery and too liquidy.
And sometimes so is
six. So you have to you
clearly just show them
a picture and be like
what does your poop
look like and then they'll
be super embarrassed
um but this is a great
way of objectively
objectively knowing what
their stool may look
like um so that's what
we use the bristle
score um so this can
be very common because
uh kids start using
public toilets and it
can be very common
for them to withhold
their stool or their
urine because they don't
want to use the
toilets. So with that
withholding, what happens
is the ****** gets
dilated. And then with
the dilation, they
lose normal kind of
function to contract.
And that can cause
chronic constipation.
This can also be
associated with UTI. So
when they withhold their
poop, they also withhold
their urine. So that
doesn't help. um
so really examining the
belly because sometimes
you can feel a lot
of stool in the left
lower quadrant and then
always asking about
elimination um you know
using the score like
we talked about um
sometimes if they don't
believe you you can
get a kub abdominal
film which is what this
is to somehow prove
to them that they are
constipated because some
some parents and some
kids will tell you
swear to god i poop every
day and it's bristle
type 4 like you know
no big deal um Um,
so, uh, at that
time I usually
get an x-ray
if I'm really
convinced that
it's, it's, um,
uh, constipation,
but the parents or
the patient won't,
won't, uh, accept
it. Um, and this
one, I can show
them like, look
how much stool you
have. And then they're
like, oh, okay.
Um, and the treatment
for this is really
to increase fiber in
your diet. Um, and
in kids, we usually
tell than prune juice,
pear juice, or plum
juice are really
great ways to increase
bowel motility because
it serves as an osmotic
agent. Basically,
the sugar kind of
draws in water and
then allows it to
have softer bowel
movements, which is
exactly what Miralax does
as well, which comes
in a powder form.
And usually you
twist off the cap and
then put the powder
in the cap and
then measure it
and then put it in
water or juice,
mix it really well
until it dissolves
and then drink it.
Usually these patients
need Miralax every
single day until they
clear out better.
And sometimes they can
get really constipated
where they need
actually an *****,
which is a medicine
up the ****** to help
kind of let go of some
of these hard balls
that are stuck in the
******. um this is
not to be confused
with appendicitis
because um appendicitis
can also can is usually
more in like older
patients but um you
cannot rule it out
so that's why exam
skills are really
important so remember your
mcburnies points
remember your psoas sign
your obturator sign
remember rebound
guarding all those things
are really important
for determining
whether this is just
constipation or it
could be appendicitis.
Okay, let's talk about
scoliosis. So scoliosis
usually is found in
adolescents greater
than or at 11 years
of age. The onset is
quite variable though,
but in our clinic, we
check for scoliosis
in all young patients.
So what you want to
do is called the Adams
Forward Bend Test.
And you basically have
them stand up straight
and put their arms
out to the side, try to
level their shoulders.
And what we do with
the shoulders is
make sure that their
shoulders look even. So
does this one match
up with this one? And
does this scapula
match up with this one?
And if they're uneven,
that can clue you in
that there's some
sort of curvature of
their spine. And then
we have them slowly bend
forward and try to
touch their knees and
a normal spine will
be nice and straight
like this, whereas the
deformity from scoliosis
will cause one side
to be more of a
hump than the other side
because those muscles
are kind of more
prominent because the
bones are more prominent
on that side. So as
you can see in this
picture, the hip creases
and the shoulders
are a great way to
assess for structural
scoliosis even before
you had them do the
the um the forward bend
test okay this is a
great test that we do
we also have scoliometer
so um uh it's
sort of like a uh if
you guys have put up
construction or like
um the little measuring
things that have
the little liquid
thing in between in the
bubble you're supposed
to get it right in
between so it's like
that there's a
little ball and it's
supposed to hit right
in between if the spine
is at a normal
curvature versus if it's
if it's a little
bit curved, then the
ball will be off to
the side. So we have
that in clinic. So
if you rotate with us
in centralized lab,
we'll show it to you.
Okay. Lastly,
I want to talk
about tanner
staging. So tanner
staging is
super important.
And you guys will
learn this a little bit
in the adolescent
lecture as well. But you
want to make sure that
the puberty is on time
and not precocious.
So this on the images
right here will show
you the pubertal stages
for girls at the
top and then boys at
the bottom. So for
girls, we actually have
two things that we look
for. So we look for
breast development and
also their ***** hair.
And for that, they
actually get two tanner
stages because
sometimes those are not
both the same number.
So you can say tanner
stage two in breasts
and tanner stage three
in ***** hair. So you
can say that that's
normal to do. And a
pediatric endocrinologist
will also encourage
you to do that because
it specifies exactly
what you see. So
remember, *****, you
don't have much of growth
of anything and you
don't have any hair.
Two, tanner stage
two, you have a
breast bud and
really no hair.
It's very fine and
nothing really.
three you can get
breast elevation
a little bit and then you
start getting a
little bit of the
finer hair but it's
still fine stage four
the ****** mounds so as
you can see the ******
kind of like forms a
little mound so it's
like up and then for
***** hair now you
have more coarser hair
that's really around
the mons *****. Stage
five is when you start
getting adult contour
of the breast. And
then for ***** hair,
it's really you get
growth into more extension
into the mon *****,
but also the medial
aspects of the thighs.
So that's standard
stage five for women.
For boys, standard
stage one starts with
the testicular size,
usually less than
four cc's in volume,
and the length is
usually 2.5 centimeters,
okay? Then stage
two starts a little
bit with ***********
of the ******* and
the ******, and
then the scrotal skin
changes to more of a
red and has a little
bit more texture.
Here at this point is
the start of puberty,
so the ****** growing
to four CACs or
MLs or higher will
actually indicate to
you that they've
started puberty, okay?
Stage three is when
now you get ***********
of the ***** and it
increases in length
at first, and then
you get further growth
of the ******, get a
little bit of hair.
In stage four, you
get a little bit more
hair and it's a little
bit finer and thicker.
And then you get
increased size of
your ***** with
growth in the birth,
breath, and also the
development of the
glands. The ******
and the *******
are larger and the
skin grows darker.
At this point, we
have ********* that
are about 16 cc's
in volume, right?
And then stage
five, obviously, is
adult genitalia
when you get that
coarse hair in
the ***** area and
also in the medial
thighs, okay?
This over here, the
string of beads, is
actually used by pediatric
endocrinologists.
It's an orchidometer
and basically you can
use it to measure the
size of the mLs of
the ********* to see
at what stage they're
in. And this really
helps with pre
-precocious puberty and
also delayed puberty as
well. Okay, let's talk
a little bit about
precocious puberty.
So that's defined as
all girls younger
than six, so anything
younger than six, so
five and below, with any
breast or ***** hair
development, okay?
Girls younger than
eight years of age with
both breast and *****
hair development,
and then girls younger
than eight with only
breast or ***** hair,
you have to do a
careful history and
exam with maybe a bone
age to determine and
then have a close
follow-up. You can
get isolated *********
thalarchy, which is
growth of the breasts,
or ********* adnarchy,
which is just growth
of the ***** hair
before any of the other
symptoms of puberty.
So for For example,
they'll have isolated
***** hair, but no
growth of their
breasts, no armpit hair,
no menarche, obviously,
no signs of having
odor to their armpits
or acne, and that
can be benign. This
usually is more common
in overweight girls.
You'll see this
often, and that
usually requires
reassurance. Okay. As
long as there's no
other development
of other ******
characteristics.
For boys,
precocious puberty is
the onset of secondary
****** characteristics
before the age
of nine. So usually
stage two, like Tanner
stage two starts at
about nine to 14, and
then it carries on.
um and then delayed
puberty we can talk
about in the adolescent
lecture which i think
dr chan gives you guys
but um so that's kind
of it for that uh
precocious puberty
can be central or
peripheral so central uh
the gonadotropin hormone
is just secreting a
lot or peripheral um
it's something else
maybe a tumor or
something that's
secreting that the extra
hormone so um just
something to keep in mind.
Okay, that was
it. Thank you for
watching. If you have
questions, please
email me and please
give feedback
on the lecture.
Thank you. Have a
great day. And these
are my resources.